in the event a true conflict reaches the
shores of the United States do we just
sit back and say Biden is our president
and we're gonna he's got it I still have
faith the system will work in regards to
like that's not something you can ignore
right so and this is kind of comes back
a little bit
like so you've got
uh secretary Austin his secretary of
defense you have Mark milley you can say
what you want General Millie's the
chairman The Joint Chiefs of Staff they
will go to the president and say this is
what has to be done
you know there now the question is
what's their guidance going to be but at
the end of the day you know that's like
an act of War so we are gonna we're
gonna go to war over that if we've got
now you could art let's talk about that
spy balloon was that an act of war that
it violated our airspace well we let it
right we go on all day about that